Berlin hest 16 octobre 2009 le Nice
Museum qui vient d'être restauré réouvre
ses portes c'est ici que l'on peut
admirer la plus belle collection de
régimes
mais le véritable événement c'est
l'arrivée d'une des reines les plus
célèbres de l'histoire d'Egypte le buste
de Néfertiti
un chef-d'œuvre qui était exposé depuis
20 ans dans le vieux musée de Berlin
aujourd'hui Néfertiti change d'adresse
pour venir trôner ou neuf Museum
[Musique]
je crois que c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
absolu et en plus un chef-d'œuvre
intemporel
quelle impression de perfection de
plénitude esthétique en fait on voit une
beauté parfaite d'où est-ce que ça vient
c'est son histoire qui en a fait une
star
vous savez c'est un peu comme votre Mona
Lisa
c'est l'icône de l'identité égyptienne
Néfertiti
âgé de plus de 3000 ans toutes les
précautions sont prises pour ne pas
égratigner ce visage vierge de tout
défaut son état de conservation est
d'ailleurs une des plus grandes énigmes
dans l'histoire des découvertes
archéologiques
mais la fête est gâchée par un scandale
venant de Genève et relayé par la presse
française le buste de Néfertiti est
accusé des trains faux à l'origine de
cette polémique une enquête menée
pendant plus de 20 ans par l’historien
Henri
sur le fait que ça soit une copie un
faux un modèle une maquette ça et pour
moi il y a aucun doute
ce qui a d'abord éveillé les soupçons de
l'historien c'est l'état de conservation
exceptionnelle dans lequel le bus venait
fertiti a été trouvé cet objet était
tellement incongru quelque chose qui
était complètement différent de ce qu'on
attendait de la part d'un buste égyptien
qui datait de 3300 ans pour l'historien
en ristirlin le buste donnait fertiti
est donc bien conservé trop peut-être
trop neuf pour être vrai et puis il y a
cet autre buste trouver à côté de celui
de Néfertiti il s'agit du buste du
pharaon Akhenaton son mari totalement
défiguré
comment t'expliquer que ces deux bustes
trouvés au même endroit et au même
moment soit dans un état de conservation
si différent
alors le buste de Néfertiti serait-il un
faux
[Musique]
à Montpellier l'archéologue egyptologue
Marc gabold spécialiste de Néfertiti
répond aux accusations d'Henry stirlin
il faut se dire qu'il a eu raison de
poser la question que les arguments
qu'il a fournis ne sont pas suffisants
si on arrive à me donner des arguments
scientifiques forts comme quoi c'est un
faux je me résoudrai restera toujours
une petite un petit élément de doute on
sait jamais
retour dans les sous-sols du œil Museum
où est organisé une conférence de presse
les journalistes invités prennent des
notes mais aucune question sur les
accusations à propos de l'authenticité
du buste car remettre en cause le bus de
Néfertiti outre-Rhin est tabou car ce
buste découvert par l'archéologue
allemand Ludwig borschacht il y a près
d'un siècle en Egypte et devenu un
symbole en Allemagne nous avons
néanmoins posé la question à Madame
zayfrid directrice du noys museum
on ne se pose pas la question que ce bus
est authentique va de soi
serait-il faut
de nombreux archéologues français
italiens américains émettent des doutes
sur l'authenticité de ce buste aucun n'a
souhaité nous répondre officiellement
nous avons donc décidé de mener notre
propre enquête vous verrez que tout le
monde se tient par la barbichette et que
personne n'ose se mouiller dans ses
opérations pour déclarer que l'objet est
véritablement un faux alors le buste le
plus célèbre de l'histoire de l'Égypte
est-il un faux nous avons rencontré les
plus grands experts sur la question
soumis le buste au détecteur de
mensonges remontez le cours de
l'histoire ce que nous avons découvert
dans cette enquête changera à jamais
votre regard sur la plus mystérieuse
reine d'Égypte et sa représentation le
buste de Néfertiti
[Musique]
qui était Néfertiti voilà un des plus
grands mystères de l'histoire
pharaonique de l'Égypte des générations
d'archéologues ont fouillé derrière tous
les monuments
décrypter jacquéroglyphe gravés sur les
pylônes et les murs des temples pour
tenter de traquer le moindre indice
évoquant son existence
pour retrouver les premières traces de
la reine Néfertiti les archéologues ont
remonté le cours du Nil jusqu'à Carnac
dans un des centres religieux les plus
importants d'Egypte
c'est dans ce labyrinthe de temple et de
colonnes que l'on a enfin trouvé la
première image de la reine Néfertiti
une image gravée délicatement sur une
pierre ayant appartenu à un temple
disparu
mais des origines de Néfertiti on ne
sait rien probablement égyptienne mais
surtout première épouse du célèbre
pharaon de la 18e dynastie le grand
Akhenaton
Néfertiti était l'épouse principale
d'Akhenaton c'était la seule femme qui
était en droit de porter le titre de
grand épouse du roi on connaît les sœurs
de la reine et on connaît sa nourrice
mais de l'origine de la famille de
Néfertiti on ne sait rien si je veux
être honnête je dois vous dire on ne
sait pas c'est la reine d'Égypte dont on
possède le plus de représentations le
plus de documents qui l'évoque et c'est
peut-être une de celle dont on sait le
moins
on ne connaît pas les parents de
Néfertiti mais ce qui nous frappe c'est
sa beauté unique avec ce visage qui nous
paraît au premier regard si moderne
si l'on connaît le nom de la reine
Néfertiti c'est grâce à son époux
Akhenaton le rebelle l’hérétique car ce
pharaon s'est rendu célèbre en faisant
table rase de tous les dieux égyptiens
pour imposer un seul Dieu atone le dieu
soleil
tout son règne pendant la 18e dynastie
Akhenaton construit de nouveaux temples
à ciel ouvert pour permettre aux rayon
de l'astre solaire de diffuser leur
bienfaits
dans sa nouvelle religion le pharaon
Akhenaton développe le culte de la
personnalité car désormais Akhenaton est
le dieu soleil ne font qu'un
Néfertiti et Akhenaton ont également
formé le couple le plus romantique de
toutes les dynasties araoniques
leur amour l'un pour l'autre a débuté
très tôt sur cette stature ils sont âgés
à peine 14 ans le peuple découvre pour
la première fois deux adolescents maître
d'un empire se tenant par la main dans
les représentations ils sont très
amoureux l'un de l'autre ce que l'on
voit tout à fait étonnant c'est le roi
d'arène s'embrassait ils sont sur le
chat royal et Akhenaton embrasse
Néfertiti Néfertiti est en train de
poser un collier au coût d'Akhenaton et
elle en profite pour lui voler un petit
baiser au passage donc on a une très
très grande intimité qui est représentée
qui est certainement le reflet
d'un grand amour
Akhenaton est Néfertiti quitte la région
de Carnac pour venir s'installer au
centre de l'Egypte à tel et la Marnaz au
milieu d'un désert c'est là qu'il
construisent une nouvelle cité royale
qu'ils vont baptiser Hackett Aton
l'horizon du soleil le plus célèbre
couple de l'histoire d'Egypte va vivre
dans une ville moderne construite
rapidement pouvant accueillir 50000
habitants
une cité dotée de nombreux temples sans
toi car Akhenaton est Néfertiti consacre
la majorité de leur temps à l'adoration
du dieu soleil
mais le règne d'Akhenaton est de
néfertitine durera que 17 ans
après leur mort leur successeur
effaceront toute trace de leur existence
et démontrons les palais pierre par
pierre en moins d'une trentaine d'années
la cité se videra de ses habitants et
redeviendra un désert
c'est un petit peu une Pompéi des sables
et quand on fouille les bâtiments qui
datent de la 18e dynastie on a quel
niveau d'occupation en quelque sorte
celui de l'époque d'Akhenaton et c'est
une ville qui a vécu en gros une
quinzaine d'années donc ce qui est très
très peu on a un instantané de la vie
égyptienne
c'est dans ce désert de 10 km de long
sur 5 km de large que le 6 décembre 1912
le buste de Néfertiti surgit intacte au
milieu de nulle part
Ludwig borschard est né à Berlin en 1863
c'était le plus célèbre archéologue
également de son époque l'Egypte ces
monuments et son architecture facile
borschach vers 1906 l'archéologue
allemand décide de fouiller la cité
d'Akhenaton une ville fantôme pour les
uns une vaste scène de crime pour
l'archéologue car borschacht est un
finlier il est persuadé qu'il va faire
le coup du siècle
et c'est le 6 décembre 1912 entouré de
son équipe qu'il aurait fait la grande
découverte de sa vie
le célèbre buste donnait fertiti
ce buste taillé dans le calcaire émerge
sous 50 cm de gravat Porsche ressuscite
une reine intacte presque vivante avec
toutes ses couleurs
mais comment l'archéologue port Chartres
aurait-il fait jaillir ce chef-d'œuvre
au milieu de nulle part
[Musique]
avant l'arrivée de l'allemand l'ancienne
cité d'Akhenaton était la chasse gardée
des Anglais et de leur chef archéologue
flyerspettri lui et ses équipes en 1891
et 1892 avait déjà fouillé partout ils
avaient tout ouvert les tombes
découvert les magnifiques fresques des
hauts dignitaires mise à jour les
fondations des palais mais jamais ils
n'ont découvert un chef-d'œuvre comme
cette Néfertiti
l'arrivée de l'archéologue allemand
borschacht en 1906 fait sourire les
Anglais hirricane même ils sont
persuadés que l'allemand fera chou blanc
à la fin du 19e siècle
pour lui c'était fini il était sûr qu'il
n'y avait plus rien à trouver
ce ne fut pas le cas
parce qu'il s'intéressait à l'urbanisme
égyptien
mais il avait un autre plan
il était en contact avec le musée de
Berlin et il voulait ramener quelque
chose de spectaculaire à Berlin
[Musique]
en ce début de 20ème siècle l’egypte est
le plus grand terrain de chasse pour les
archéologues du monde entier dans cette
course au trésor la Prusse est en retard
Guillaume II charge alors borschach de
ramener un trophée à tout prix avant de
commencer ses fouilles l'archéologue
malin se renseigne auprès des
antiquaires du vieux Caire qui
trafiquent avec les pilleurs
c'est là qu'il apprend qu'une partie de
la cité d'Akhenaton n'a pas été encore
fouillé
borschacht est aussi un architecte alors
dès son arrivée il aurait établi un plan
de la zone Sud-Est celle du quartier des
artisans
là où ni les anglais ni les pilleurs ne
sont allés gratter
et s'intéressent à l'habitat donc il va
fouiller d'abord les grandes villas qui
se distinguent sur le site parce que
elle forme un petit monticule et puis il
va étendre ses fouilles à l'habitat un
petit peu plus commun et par
extraordinaire il va tomber à un moment
donné sur l'officine et la villa du
sculpteur toute Mosis qui va être le
point d'orgue de ces fouilles
grâce à sa méthode borschach identifie
rapidement une propriété composée de
plusieurs ateliers de sculpteur
excités l'archéologue visite le jardin
ératisse le moindre centimètre carré
c'est là qu'il identifie derrière ces
silos une maison qui aurait appartenu au
chef des sculpteurs d'Akhenaton et de
Néfertiti
c'est dans cette maison que borschach
aurait découvert le buste de Néfertiti
intrigué par ce miracle nous avons voulu
retourner un siècle plus tard sur les
traces de l'archéologue Ludwig
borschacht retrouvez la maison dans
laquelle le buste a été découvert
direction le sud à 5 heures de route du
Caire où se trouve telle est la Marnaz
la cité fantôme d'Akhenaton est donnée
fertiti
nous sommes accompagnés de Luc vatrin
archéologue chasseur de fonds et expert
en objets d'art de l’égypte antique
auprès des tribunaux et de l'archéologue
égyptien Hamada inspecteur général du
chantier de fouille de telena marna
voilà le rapport de Borde sur le bus de
néfertity
version
[Musique]
a emporté avec lui un document
exceptionnel les notes et les croquis de
l'archéologue Ludwig borschach dans
lesquelles il raconte tout de sa
découverte du buste en 1912
ce document va nous aider à retrouver
l'endroit exact où le buste de Néfertiti
aurait été découvert
voilà ce qu'il reste 3300 ans plus tard
de l'atelier du chef sculpteur toute
Mosis
ces quelques parts dans une de ces
pièces que borschach l'archéologue
allemand aurait découvert le buste de
Néfertiti plan en main l'archéologue
lucvatrin décrypte les lieux alors là
effectivement c'est mentant vous avez la
salle de réception du propriétaire de la
villa c'est très certainement ici que
ces autres de marques venaient mais
également pourquoi pas venait poser les
hauts personnages de l'État et pourquoi
pas la reine des fertilis elle-même
alors on quitte la salle de la réception
et là
bien évidemment on arrive sur l'atelier
du sculpteur derrière la porte borde est
très précis dans ses écrits qu'est-ce
qui découvre dans cet angle ici le bus
de la reine
d'après borschacht Néfertiti était là
enfoui depuis 3200 ans et pourtant si
vivante et ce n'est pas fini la maison
du chef des sculpteurs d'Akhenaton
regorge de trésors borschach découvre
dans les autres pièces la plus belle
collection de bustes de l'époque
d'Akhenaton des masques de plâtre à
l'aspect étrangement réaliste des
modèles d'ateliers comme celui
d'Akhenaton lui-même un modèle inachevé
et le fameux buste des figurer du
pharaon Akhenaton trouvé juste à côté de
celui de Néfertiti Ludwig Borchard offre
ainsi au musée de Berlin ses plus beaux
trophées
mais dans ce conte de fées pour
archéologue un détail va retenir
l'attention d'un historien un élément
qui va déclencher une enquête digne d'un
roman policier
[Musique]
OK dans sa maison coloniale
l'archéologue Ludwig borschart mettra
étrangement plus d'une dizaine d'années
pour livrer un rapport complet sur ses
fouilles de telle à la marna de 1912
il est relate l'histoire de la
découverte du buste en calcaire de
Néfertiti et de celle d'un autre buste
lui aussi en calcaire trouvait juste à
côté le buste du pharaon Akhenaton au
visage éclaté dans ses relevés
topographiques borschach a soigneusement
noté l'emplacement du buste de Néfertiti
mais il a également dessiné
l'emplacement du fameux buste défiguré
d'Akhenaton
d'après les plans de l'archéologue le
buste donnait fertiti était posé sur une
étagère dans l'angle de l'atelier
[Musique]
c'est au sol à l'entrée à gauche que
borschacht découvre d'abord le buste
d'Akhenaton
puis le temps fait son ouvrage le mur
extérieur ce serait effondré et le buste
de Néfertiti avec
Akhenaton est retrouvé en plusieurs
morceaux
alors que Néfertiti juste à côté est un
acte comme si elle venait de sortir de
l'atelier du sculpteur étrange cette
histoire ne serait qu'une supercherie
une imposture de bord Chartres c'est ce
qu'affirme l'historien Suisse en
ristirlin qui a enquêté pendant plus de
20 ans il remet en question le rapport
de borschach et accuse tout simplement
Néfertiti d'être trop belle pour être
authentique
comment est-ce qu'il est possible qu'un
objet aussi lourd aussi délicat avec une
peinture absolument intacte puisse
tomber comme
borschach le suppose d'un rayonnage qui
est à peu près à 1 m 50 du sol dans des
éboulis dans des
cailloutis sans s'abîmer surtout que il
indique que l'objet est tombé face
contre terre et puis il se dit que c'est
comme un objet tellement délicat que
c'est pas possible que les seuls
éléments qui ont été abîmés c'est les
oreilles or les oreilles les autres pas
en contact brutal avec le sol quand
l'objet tombe
au début de l’enquête en 1984 en
ristirlin confie ses douta Dietrich
villedoung un des plus grands
égyptologues allemands hors de tout
soupçon à l'époque il est directeur du
Musée de Munich il a étudié le bus
pendant de longues années et donne
raison et encourage même en ristirlin
dans une lettre
j'ai tenu de recevoir une lettre qui me
dit votre projet est tout à fait
concluant il est convaincant il le dit
dans une lettre qu'il m'a envoyé
où il dit
c'est Lucie ou ubersheim cohérent
dans ce courrier Dietrich ville donc
confirme également que lui aussi a des
doutes sur l'étrange état de
conservation de Néfertiti que son style
ne correspond pas à celui de l'époque
d'Akhenaton et qu'il est même prêt à
faire la préface de son enquête puis en
1989 il est nommé conservateur du buste
de Néfertiti effet volte-face et puis
subitement Villedo m'envoie une autre
lettre
ou il m'annonce qu'il est nommé comme
directeur du musée Berlin
évidemment Berlin c'est la ville où est
conservée le buste de Néfertiti et tout
le problème se repose d'une manière
complètement différente pour lui il me
dit qu'il est obligé de prendre ces
distances avec le projet et il peut plus
s'engager mais en plus chose qui me
semble déjà plus inquiétant il m'envoie
deux émissaires de Berlin du musée de
Berlin qui sont tous les deux des
égyptologues deux émissaires qui sont
chargés de me dissuader de continuer le
marché
mais l'historien en vestiaire l'un n'est
pas un homme à se laisser impressionner
il va enquêter sans relâche mais
désormais seul contre tous
intrigué par cette histoire nous
retournons à Berlin pour un rendez-vous
programmé avec Dietrich villedong la
veille de notre rencontre l'expert
archéologue annule l'interview nous le
rappelons feignant de ne pas avoir reçu
son message
[Musique]
allô
oui monsieur Dietrich ville donc
je vous appelle parce que nous avons
rendez-vous demain pour une interview au
sujet de Néfertiti je voulais savoir à
quelle heure on se retrouvait
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
de mon sujet
haut
de grande on apprendra plus tard que les
autorités allemandes ont interdit
formellement monsieur villedong de
communiquer sur le buste de Néfertiti et
d'évoquer l'enquête d'enrichirlin
pour l'historien le buste de la reine
serait le fruit d'une expérience
borschach aurait fait fabriquer une
copie du buste de Néfertiti
borschacht voulait étudier la technique
de la sculpture sur plâtre et surtout la
façon dont les Égyptiens utilisaient la
couleur et pour cela bordchard aurait dû
à sa disposition des matériaux trouvés
sur place dans les fouilles de telle à
la Marnaz
il a tout sur place
je vais le plâtre c'est pas compliqué à
faire c'est un datable
et puis la pierre qui est au centre
c'est parce qu'il manque en Egypte et
Pierre vous voyez c'est vraiment le pays
de du calcaire on sort en gros bloc de
calcaire on les pauvre pour juste qu'ils
prennent à peu près la forme de la
statue qu'on va faire et puis on met du
plâtre et là le sculpteur entre en
action elle fait véritablement
une copie des visages qu'il avait en
grande quantité dans les découvertes qui
avait été faites des objets authentiques
[Musique]
comme ce buste un authentique modèle de
Néfertiti inachevé trouvé également dans
l'atelier de toute messe le sculpteur
d'Akhenaton sur celui-ci on remarque des
traces de charbon elles indiquent les
parties restantes à sculpter pour
Chartres aurait-il utilisé un modèle
comme celui-ci trouvez sur place et qui
aurait ensuite été coloré
borschacht qui le dit très clairement
dans ces carnets de fouilles avaient
découvert des pigments en grande
quantité nous le dit et qui sont prêtes
à l'emploi
mais alors s'il s'agissait d'une copie
expérimentale comment expliquer que
borschach n'en ai jamais parlé à son
entourage ou dans son rapport de fouille
d'après historien le 5 décembre 1912
l'archéologue borschach est au Caire il
apprend qu'une des familles princières
de la future Allemagne de passage en
Egypte souhaite visiter son chantier de
fouilles porschacht prix de cours
rejoint un tel à la marna au plus vite
le jour de son arrivée le 6 décembre
1912 devait être un jour de repos pour
les ouvriers il remet immédiatement ses
équipes au travail
puis fièrement présente aux altesses le
fruit de ses recherches par Excel le
contremaître des fouilles s'émoussi
l'égyptien s'absente à l'instant et
revient avec la reine Néfertiti dans les
bras la famille royale s'extasie devant
le chef-d'oeuvre un photographe
immortalise l'événement
borschacht n'aurait pas eu le temps
d'expliquer aux Altesse qu'il s'agissait
d'une copie et non d'un authentique
d'après Henri Sterlin cette photo sera
le piège qui se refermera sur
l'archéologue
on peut pas comme ça dire à des Altesse
qui sont en train de s'extasier devant
un objet écoutez vous vous trompez c'est
ridicule on ridiculise les Altesse il a
été tenu de ne pas démentir auquel cas
c'était il couvrait de ridicule les
Altesse royales et c'était un crime de
l'Est majesté qui à l'époque était quand
même quelque chose de très grave et
pouvait
vraiment porter atteinte à toute sa
carrière
après la visite royale le buste va
disparaître étrangement pendant près de
11 ans
porschacht Laura confié discrètement à
son mécène James Simon c'est grâce à ce
riche industriel que l'archéologue a pu
financer une partie de ses fouilles
a-t-elle et la Marnaz
quand James a reçu le message de la
découverte du buste il était très excité
tout Berlin attendait le retour de la
reine mais le buste a terminé sur la
commode de chez mon arrière-grand-père
pendant plus de 10 ans
de 1912 à 1924 borschacht refusera
systématiquement d'exposer la reine en
public
[Musique]
je m'étais pas rendu compte que l'oeil
qui manquait était aussi une atteinte
aussi forte son portrait à son image
Néfertiti borne un crime de lèse majesté
un sacrilège porté à l'image pharaonique
de la grande reine d'Égypte pour
vérifier cet argument nous nous rendons
à l'Université de Liège en Belgique chez
Dimitri Laboury c'est un des plus grands
spécialistes de l'histoire de l'art et
de l'archéologie en Égypte pharaonique
il nous livre son expertise sur le sujet
c'est un buste d'atelier c'est un objet
utilitaire en fait c'est un bus qui est
destiné à permettre au sculpteur de
reproduire de façon fidèle l'image
canonique devenait faire Titi telle
qu'elle a été décidée par Akhenaton et
probablement par Néfertiti elle-même
aussi
pour le professeur Laborie ce buste
comme d'autres objets royaux étaient un
outil de communication la représentation
officielle de la reine Néfertiti devait
être reconnaissable au premier coup
d'oeil par les prêtres le peuple du nord
au sud de l'Égypte une sorte de Marianne
pharaonique
quant à l'oeil borgne qui choque
l'Historia en ristirlin d'après les
experts il servirait de modèle pour
indiquer la forme et la profondeur
exacte qu'il faut sculpter pour ensuite
incruster correctement les yeux de
Néfertiti
pour Dimitri Laboury ce buste Royal
était un modèle d'atelier typique du
style de la famille d'Akhenaton
[Musique]
si on regarde la bouche d'Akhenaton si
on regarde la bouche des princesses à
marnieres si on regarde la bouche du
beau-père de Néfertiti et les traiter
avec ce même sensualisme de façon
différente mais l'esthétique même est
semblable mais l'élément déterminant en
faveur de l'authenticité du buste aurait
été démontré par un des meilleurs
égyptologues allemands rollscroys
ce que l'on sait
c'est que ce buste a été fabriqué selon
une grille de proportion
mais celle du doigt égyptien
dans leur système de mesure les Anglais
ont le pied ou le pouce
en référence
pour créer un nouveau buste le sculpteur
d'Akhenaton aurait dessiné au préalable
une grille de référence pour les
sculpteurs des autres régions d'Egypte
chaque ligne était calculée sur la
largeur d'un doigt
le buste de Néfertiti devait
correspondre à cette unité rolls cross a
mis également en évidence que certaines
intersections correspondaient
systématiquement à des points
anatomiques précis sur le visage comme
ceux de la base du nez ou de la bouche
ainsi la longueur du visage de la reine
est calibrée de la base du menton à
celle de la coiffe elle est construite
suivant une grille de proportion
calculée en unité de mesure égyptienne
1,875 cm le doigt égyptien ce qui fait
que
elle est métriquement construite et il
aurait fallu que le faussaire sache à
l'époque qu'il fallait utiliser le
centimètre égyptien et non le centimètre
actuel
cette grille de proportion aurait permis
de standardiser la fabrication du buste
de Néfertiti dans toutes les gîtes
apparemment les faussaires du début du
19e siècle ignorait cette particularité
mais il y a une autre anomalie qui fait
dire à l'historien que ce buste est une
aberration les épaules coupées
verticalement les bras
de ce buste était coupé à la verticale
or
à quelques très très rares exceptions
près
c'est une formule qui n'existe pas dans
la régie les bus sont coupés
horizontalement à la hauteur des épaules
et non pas verticalement
le buste de Néfertiti aux épaules
coupées verticalement serait-il un cas
unique dans l'histoire de l'Égypte pour
en savoir plus nous retournons cette
fois à Berlin au nice-muzeum sa
directrice Madame zaifri de nos affirme
qu'il existe un autre exemple de buste
aux épaules coupés verticalement ce
buste trouvé par borschach dans ses
fouilles de 1912 fait partie d'une série
d'objets jamais exposés en public
[Musique]
il existe donc un deuxième buste aux
épaules coupées dans cette bagarre
d'experts cet argument est-il suffisant
pour prouver définitivement
l'authenticité de la reine des fertiti
retour sur Berlin le noys Museum pour
tenter de mettre fin à toutes ses
rumeurs a décidé de soumettre le buste
de Néfertiti au détecteur de mensonges
la science va-t-elle prouver son
authenticité le buste a été transféré à
l'hôpital de la Charité de Berlin pour y
subir un scanner on peut enfin voir ce
que Néfertiti a dans la tête
première constatation le buste est formé
d'un noyau calcaire un noyau enrobé de
plâtre une technique qui a permis au
sculpteur ou au faussaire de modifier
certaines parties du buste
ce qui signifie que Néfertiti aurait été
retouchée
vous voyez très bien ici l'épaule vue de
l'arrière la partie blanche c'est la
pierre calcaire et ce que vous voyez au
dessus en gris c'est du plâtre c'est une
application faite après la sculpture
c'est un rajout de plâtre pour corriger
ce que vous voyez très clairement sur
cette vue arrière c'est que l'épaule
droite est plus haute que la gauche
du plâtre pour corriger et renforcer la
courbe du cou du buste en calcaire de
Néfertiti et ce n'est pas fini le
sculpteur ou le faussaire a même corrigé
les joues et les pommettes du visage
ainsi que l'arête du nez de Néfertiti en
rajoutant là aussi du plâtre le premier
lifting de l'histoire mais en dehors de
cette chirurgie plastique que prouve
cette tomographie
ou la tomographie n'est pas une preuve
au contraire on ne peut en coupant des
tranches dans l’intérieur d'un objet en
rien expliqué
l'époque à laquelle cet objet est né on
peut tout simplement dire que dans cet
objet il y a un autre pierre
d'un noyau de pierre et il y a une
couche d'enveloppe qui a été sculptée
mais à quel moment on est totalement
incapable d'y répondre
on ne peut pas dire que grâce à cette
méthode ce buste est âgé de 3300 ans
reste la couche de plâtre appliquez sur
le buste en calcaire de Néfertiti ce
plâtre date-il de l'époque d'Akhenaton
les Allemands ont extrait un échantillon
de ce plâtre sur le buste de Néfertiti
pour le faire analyser par un chimiste
spécialiste des objets égyptiens
[Musique]
on retrouve un mélange d'éléments qui
existait uniquement à la période
amarnienne et en pauvre
c'est au même titre que l'architecture
et les masques
c'est-à-dire que ce mélange c'est une
invention de l'époque la composition de
ce plâtre est donc typique de la période
de Amarna
autrement dit le plâtre qui recouvre le
buste de Néfertiti était bien celui qui
était utilisé par les Égyptiens il y a
3300 ans
on ne pouvait pas connaître la
composition de ce plâtre parce que la
technique d'analyse permettant d'y
arriver a été mise au point uniquement
dans les années 50
un faussaire ne pouvait donc connaître
la composition de ce plâtre
est l'éventualité qu'il aurait pu
utiliser du plâtre trouver sur place en
1912 question pour l'instant restez sans
réponse
reste une dernière chance d'authentifier
Néfertiti grâce à la science les
pigments qui donnent cet aspect si
vivant à la reine
des pigments qui imitent parfaitement la
couleur de la peau et rendre sa bouche
si sensuel
quatre couleurs dominent la égyptien le
bleu le vert l'ocre et le jaune
la technique d'utilisation est de
mélange des pigments par les artistes
égyptiens et spécifiques à chaque
dynastie
en analysant les pigments trouvés à
telle est la marna allons-nous confirmer
l'authenticité du buste
ments démontré que c'est bien des
couleurs qui ont été utilisées dans
l'antiquité égyptienne
et la technique d'utilisation de ces
pigments a été abandonné après cette
période
mais là aussi le faussaire aurait pu
tricher rappelez-vous lors de la
découverte de Néfertiti porschach avait
trouvé sur place dans l'atelier de
toutes messe le sculpteur un petit
trésor des pigments de toutes les
couleurs
du jaune
de l'ocre tirant sur le rouge de l’ocre
Claire et même le fameux bleu
lapis-lazuli
[Musique]
à la fin du règne d'Akhenaton quand les
artisans sculpteurs ont abandonné leurs
ateliers de tel à la marna ils ont
emporté les choses les plus importantes
certainement une grande partie des
réserves de pigments mais c'est vrai ils
en ont laissé quelques-uns sur place
reste à
des pigments suffisamment pour colorer
une reine alors Néfertiti vrai ou fausse
du côté des experts il n'y a aucun doute
toutes les analyses historiques et
scientifiques sont catégoriques les
matériaux sont donc authentiques mais il
y a un problème une contradiction un
doute aucun des matériaux dont elle est
constituée ne permet de lui donner un
âge
aucune expertise scientifique ne permet
alors actuelle de dater des sculptures
en pierre la reine polychrome à
l'Éternel jeunesse continuera pendant de
longues années à défier la science et
comme toutes les grandes dames de
l'histoire a caché son âge
au début du 20e siècle les bourgeois
passionnés d'Egypte jouent aux
explorateurs en suivant les traces des
archéologues
la découverte du bus se donnait faire
Titi par l'archéologue Ludwig borschacht
a déclenché un engouement particulier
pour les objets datant de l'époque
d'Akhenaton mais elle a si ils sont très
rares sur le marché
[Musique]
cas cela ne tiennent les faussaires vont
se mettre au travail
ok au début du 20e siècle un certain
Émile Bruges va trouver la bonne combine
il va fournir à des artistes des œuvres
authentiques pour les faire copier et en
faire défaut rien de plus facile pour ce
petit futé à l'époque il est responsable
du magasin des antiquités égyptiennes au
musée du Caire
pendant une période le musée autorisé
ses collaborateurs donc surtout les
restaurateurs à prendre des objets chez
eux pour
les étudier
certains de ces restaurateurs
deviendront de redoutable faussaire il
ne reste aucune trace aujourd'hui de
leur identité
voici les deux seules photos connues
d'un faussaire vers 1910 celle d'un
maltée du nom de Paulo dingly peintre
sculpteur et faussaire à ses heures il
exerçait son art à domicile
petite anecdote qui a son importance
Ludwig borschach le fréquentait
régulièrement
pour les collections allemandes des
musées
était florissant
il fallait à tout prix éviter de faire
de mauvaises achats
et les faussaires sont nombreux à cette
époque difficile d'évaluer aujourd'hui
leur production mais néanmoins une
question se pose
existe-t-il encore des faux de cette
époque exposés dans les musées
au monde qui ne possède pas de faux
serres temps de travail de très grande
qualité et en tant qu'expert nous ne
sommes jamais à l'abri d'acheter un
faute
et même nous dans nos réserves on
possède des faux
qui pour la plupart remonte aux années
cent ans plus tard la capitale
égyptienne et ses 16 millions
d'habitants Abritel encore des
faussaires aussi doués que ceux de la
première génération
pour tenter de les rencontrer nous avons
pris contact avec l'un d'entre eux
Luc vatrin archéologue et chasseur de
faux nous accompagnent
pour rencontrer ces faussaires nous
quittons le Caire pour prendre la
direction de même fils
alors on se dirige là vers Memphis
l'aNTIC Memphis qui se situe à 25 km au
sud du Caire où se trouve donc une zone
d'atelier où vivent et travaillent les
plus
performants des
contrefacteurs égyptiens
oh
là là ça va être chaud dans tous les cas
faut être prudent mais le fait de
pouvoir aussi de parler l'arabe va nous
aider je pense à instaurer une confiance
assez rapidement
le repère des faussaire dans la banlieue
du Caire se situe à mitrainer un
quartier sensible aucun touriste ne
s'aventurent ici pour entrer en contact
avec les faussaires nous ne faisons
passer pour de gros acheteurs
travaillant pour le compte de
collectionneurs fortunés
nous avons rendez-vous avec maudire un
jeune faussaire
[Rires]
en ce moment nous dire travail sur du
calcaire
il nous propose de sculpter une petite
tête de Pharaon en moins de 10 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là on voit la technique c'est à dire les
points de repère les encoches le
calcaire qu'il a choisi est très tendre
à l'aide d'une simple râpe Moundir finit
sa démonstration en quelques minutes
[Applaudissements]
puis il trempe la sculpture dans l'eau
pour faire apparaître les nervures de
calcaire
le résultat est convaincant en nous
imaginez ce que ce jeune sculpteur
pourrait faire en deux mois de travail
d'après une œuvre originale sur une
statue en granit ou en durite
[Musique]
si je lui amène un original et ce qui
fait me le refaire à la perfection
[Applaudissements]
s
oui je peux copier et je te le ferai
vraiment bien
d'ailleurs je peux te montrer quelque
chose
de vraiment pour achever de nous
convaincre qu'il pourrait faire partie
de nos fournisseurs vous dire nous
montre un buste en granit rose sur
lequel il s'entraîne en ce moment et
qu'il a copié juste d'après une simple
photo
la pierre qui a utilisé vous dire et
vieille de 3000 ans
de quoi tromper les meilleurs experts
mais d'où vient-elle comment est-il
possible de se procurer une pierre
datant de l'époque des pharaons la
réponse se trouve à quelques centaines
de mètres de la maison de Moundir les
ruines d'un temple de l'époque de Ramsès
II
mais c'est un des c'est un des morceaux
du grand temple d'opta à l'époque
rabbécile en plein centre ville de
mitrah Inès ce site est laissé à
l'abandon sans surveillance une mine
pour les faussaires
il suffit de se pencher pour récolter
des vestiges de l'Égypte antique
dans quelques années ce site sera
entièrement pillé il ne restera plus
rien sinon que des fausses sculptées
dans la jambe de Ramsès 2
ou dans une colonne à hiéroglyphe qui
elle par contre sont authentiques
Berlin mars 2011 un an et demi après
l'inauguration du noys Muséum
des milliers de visiteurs se bousculent
pour venir rendre visite à la meilleure
ambassadrice d'Égypte en Allemagne la
reine Néfertiti la Joconde des Allemands
mais de l'autre côté de la Méditerranée
au Caire ce nouveau succès de la star du
neuf Museum a provoqué une grande colère
et réveiller des sentiments
nationalistes
au fond de la les centrale du grand
musée du Caire l'homme le plus puissant
dans le monde de l’égyptologie nous a
donné rendez-vous dans la salle dédiée
au grand pharaon Akhenaton et son épouse
Néfertiti pour une déclaration de guerre
cela fait plus de deux ans que nous
avons enquêté jusqu'à ce que nous ayons
la preuve que le buste de Néfertiti à
Berlin a été emporté de façon illégale
en dehors de l'Egypte le but de
Néfertiti devrait être aujourd'hui dans
ce musée non pas Berlin
volé par les Allemands pourquoi zahiawa
se prononce-t-il une accusation aussi
grave au début du 20e siècle le résultat
des fouilles était partagé à part égale
entre l'Egypte et les archéologues
d'après zaihawa secrétaire suprême des
antiquités en Égypte Ludwig borschach
aurait triché concernant la reine
Néfertiti
à cette époque il y avait une règle qui
disait que tout objet représentant un
roi ou une reine découverte à telle est
la Marnaz ne pouvait quitter l'Égypte
[Musique]
en 1913
le Service des Antiquités égyptiennes
demande à un français Gustave Lefebvre
d'assurer le partage des fouilles du
trésor de borschach c'est lui qui a
décidé de donner la reine Néfertiti aux
Allemands
une décision incompréhensible
comment expliquer que le français
Gustave Lefebvre est accepté de laisser
partir le plus beau buste de l'histoire
d'Egypte au musée de Berlin
voici la version officielle des
Allemands
le 17 janvier 1913 ce fameux Gustave
Lefebvre quitte le Caire pour tel est la
marna
les fouilles ont été arrêtées il y a
déjà un mois tous les objets découverts
par les Allemands ont été répertoriés et
mis en caisse
prêt à partir au musée de Berlin
Ludwig Borchard attend Gustave Lefebvre
l'allemand est nerveux car il craint que
le fer n'emporte avec lui sa plus belle
découverte
la reine Néfertiti
que s'est-il passé ce soir-là nous le
savons grâce au témoignages d'un
collègue de borschacht Bruno goutteborg
il a été le témoin de toute la scène de
partage et à tout relaté dans une lettre
a dit que les caisses étaient ouvertes
ils ont tout regardé personne n'était là
pour voir Gustave Lefebvre a fait son
choix
mais comment le faire a-t-il fait ce
choix pourquoi a-t-il laissé le buste de
Néfertiti aux Allemands
d'après goodborg le témoin du partage
borschard aurait manœuvré de façon très
habile il savait que le jeune Gustave
Lefebvre ne s'intéressait pas aux
sculptures mais était un spécialiste des
écritures anciennes
pour éviter que le ferai fouillé dès son
arrivée dans la caisse de Néfertiti
Porsche lui présente comme objet numéro
1 une stèle en couleur
représentant le couple Akhenaton
Néfertiti et les princesses
Lefèvre se jette dessus pour étudier les
hiéroglyphes
puis d’après le témoin de la scène
porschacht présenta Lefebvre non pas les
objets de ces fouilles mais des photos
en noir et blanc des photos de sculpture
des bustes de princesses et surtout une
photo de la reine Néfertiti
un portrait si majestueux que Lefèvre
aurait dû reconnaître la reine
par qui le scandale va arriver c'est
Rolf kravs ancien conservateur du musée
égyptologique de Berlin il décide enfin
de dévoiler toute la vérité sur ce
partage il affirme que Lefebvre n'a
jamais examiné le contenu des caisses
et qu'on ne lui a pas présenté la photo
de la reine des fertiti mais une autre
photo
mais alors laquelle
gouter
de Néfertiti c'est-à-dire sur la photo
on ne voyait qu'une partie du buste le
nez la bouche et les yeux mais pas la
totalité du buste
pas en couleur comme les photos
d'aujourd'hui
ce que Lefèvre aurait vu en photo c'est
donc une reine privée de sa coiffe
royale et de son collier ressemblant
tout à coup à une princesse
mais Lefèvre avait la possibilité
d'aller juger sur pièce en sortant les
objets des caisses si la vécu ce réflexe
il aurait découvert le splendide buste
de Néfertiti
on a emmené Lefèvre vers les caisses
Lefèvre n'a pas demandé à faire sortir
les pièces originales
il y avait une si jolie pièce
la beauté du buste et il a sorti
d'Egypte illégalement
borschacht aurait-il trompé Lefebvre en
lui montrant une photo tronquée de la
reine
d'après l'archéologue rolef house le but
de Néfertiti devrait se trouver
aujourd'hui au musée du Caire mais il
nous fallait une preuve définitive c'est
un document de 1913 qui va nous
l'apporter un document exceptionnel la
liste de partage officiels des fouilles
de bord chartes de 1912 écrit de la main
de Gustave Lefebvre
dans la colonne de gauche son
répertoriés les objets choisis par
Lefèvre pour le musée du Caire
l'objet numéro 1 la fameuse telle
peintre représentant Aménophis 4
Akhenaton est la reine Néfertiti jouant
avec les princesses
dans la colonne de droite parmi les
objets destinés au musée de Berlin
l'objet numéro 1 est bien un buste mais
pas celui d'une reine celui d'un buste
en plâtre peint d'une princesse de la
famille royale
la reine Néfertiti n'a donc jamais
existé officiellement dans le partage le
plus controversé de l'histoire de
l'Égypte
Néfertiti reprendre à tel un jour sa
place de Rennes en Égypte pour ne
laisser derrière elle que son ombre
royal
[Musique]